how's it going for us my name is welcome
to Catherine part three you brothers
would really seem to love this and I'm
enjoying this game so much I'm so
excited to play more it's gonna be
awesome we have a cutscene to start it
off great that's not the game we're
playing here we go [ __ ] creepy second
day Vince's room we had our first
nightmare it was kind of nice and cozy
like a sheep's belly are we pregnant now
great Oh
[Laughter]
that's not our girlfriend they can think
about is time than that right mm-hmm
no not mine oh my god all right all
right all right
stay sheep you see that president said
in the background okay well we're about
to do something stupid
she rang her nightgown oh there it is
stay sheep again well I have to work
tomorrow so oh this games yeah
hey I cheated on Catherine
it's bad this is really really bad but I
didn't make a move yeah well you went to
bed with her how do you feel about me oh
wow
I can't quite explain it feel odd you
see this is my first time
your first time what you don't even know
her name what did we get an erection
what happened what was i yes what was
that they do get angry she has a point
[Music]
so maybe she's the bad side like if you
go with the bad story or and Catherine
is the good side if you go with a good
story because marriage and commitment
seems to be good in this game second day
how oh you know what it just hit me you
know how they say every guy has three
hot streaks with the ladies in his life
this is your third who is this guy
why does everyone look Swedish in this
game this is making me hungry for sushi
[Music]
she's probably gonna kill me and that's
what you're all scared about she doesn't
find [ __ ] hat man act like it never
happened not like you I can't just
ignore this why not switch it up that
way you won't hear any more marriage
sock right all that stuff about
soulmates an eternal love is [ __ ]
life sucks man you really want to go
through the same [ __ ] I have I'm not
like you I don't want to sleep around I
just want life to stay the same oh my
god
how am I gonna do I didn't mean for any
of this to happen just live all carefree
like you don't you realize there's
nothing you can do you schmuck no matter
how good you are to a woman you never
know if she'll stab you in the back no
if you're gonna ditch the new girl and
he's married are they talking about
I guess I didn't really get much sleep
last night obviously capped by heaven
it's not a reference I feel like if you
cheat on your girlfriend who especially
if your girlfriend wants to commit to
you to your relationship and you are not
doing it then that's a good time to
probably break up with that girlfriend
instead of keep being dishonest or
whatever with her probably because your
bond is your panties nice pair of heels
like that
oh my god they jiggle alright alright
alright they say targets cheating men
and I agree with you calling pathetic
shut up peanuts what were you talking
about marriage
yeah say it louder seriously stop
yelling about cheating and [ __ ] I think
someone on Mars didn't quite hear you
love Vincent lowest of the low Joel call
me that now you know just leave me alone
well
well come on tell me about this girl
apparently she's destiny little cute are
you kidding finding your soulmate is
awesome totally jealous you jackass is
better not mention this to anyone
outside the bar I am serious
dude we know the drill say have you
heard it seems that boss was a bit of a
player back in the day and broke more
than his share of heart you see how he's
wearing those tacky sunglasses indoors
who the [ __ ] is that guy
go to sleep now if you can see you can
change the okay to these guys Johnny
Orlando English names
[Music]
there was a classmate of ours back in
high school I ran into him just the
other day
seriously how was he we just traded
greetings but he looked fine maybe I
should have paid more attention hey it's
not your fault
do we meet a sheep called Paul that died
maybe yes Orlando plus we got cursed
before we cheated she's that girl it's a
lucky accident huh
don't say that that's only if I don't
get caught yeah so you have to talk to
people to unlock some of the new story
modes for reference in the middle of the
night when she was depressed after all
[Music]
so I would say Toby is the good guy John
is the neutral and Orlando is like the
bad guy I got it when I'm to my menu
yeah I can choose to talk check phone
drink or leave see let's check our I've
got any new messages we can play the
stage two one
are you out drinking at stray sheep
again you know how I work tomorrow
ticket even again we answered today
anyway I'm confused okay
let's have a drink then let's fuxing
okay we got a message now what is it
[ __ ] sake I don't need that this game
is so unlike anything I ever played I
don't play a lot of Japanese games I'm
trying to remember which button was
drink oh yes
are we drinking Roman code you can raise
your intoxication nice corresponds to
how fast he moves that night in his
nightmare really some more drunk is
faster [ __ ] let's go alright alright
Iraq monologue comes out when you drink
we finished it you finish your glass oh
it was rum and coke no I don't know the
real name oh yeah actually didn't know
that [ __ ] the national specialties of
Cuba alright I'll have to try that then
that was the cocktail Trevor tonight
press but [ __ ] love this game giving
me lessons about drinks and [ __ ]
take your order
can own another hello I'll order whiskey
whiskey sake please I'll take a beer
yeah
[Music]
I mean I had a rough night
although hard the game is just us
hanging out what the [ __ ] is this Wow so
I can keep talking to them can I keep
drinking alright well let's not get too
good alright let's take a leak oh my god
I'm so fast rum and cola there it is let
me talk to her
Erica oh my god don't tell anyone I just
realized the voice actor is the same
from the second son what is his name
again keep forgetting it's the guy who
does voices for every [ __ ] game ever
listen Archie you've got to become a
better man with radiant hair he's a
social ladder men are only acknowledged
by their upward mobility always talk to
us I don't know how you I thought we
could encourage them let's take a scene
he teleported from the office yeah what
is our job
haven't you ever heard of Bantam suits
oh we have actually sorry those are the
guys who gave me tips at sheeps all
right so now I got a message I said from
Katherine it is are you about drinking
again I came by your apartment today but
you weren't there I want to talk to you
about something but I'll do it tomorrow
oh yeah your place is filthy I told you
you have to empty the trash more often I
took it out this time but start being
more careful okay
that's all good night should I reply man
I shouldn't reply it's not replying
we're at drinking lobbies and like I
like my blankets Wow what are you
talking about another message it must be
a bus hey Vincent if you get this let me
know okay if you do I'll send you a
picture you know you want to all right
all right all right
I like how we don't even know her name
do I know you can I change the dialogue
oh my god did I [ __ ] up something can we
go back
[Music]
let's talk to the boss nothing but
stories about those deaths he said that
there are several people who've died in
the same fashion Erica says that people
believe it's a curse given when a woman
is scorned by an unfaithful man grown
man talking about curses it just ignore
Erica a woman's guess is much more
accurate than a man you don't think it
applies to Erica
then there's nothing to worry about
Erica's guesses are never on target by
the way thank you hey boss cheated on
someone it's not like that it was an
unintentional event unintentional are
you sure about that right I ran all
right I actually don't remember oh oh I
can't really remember did you have too
much to drink besides I heard you were
wearing those shades to hide from an
ex-girlfriend come on can that girl
Texas again there's a strange room yes
you got mail now what the [ __ ] is this
time passes when you sit down and talk
to people in the bar customers will come
and go while you do this sending out
drinking checking your phone playing
arcade using the jukebox don't make the
time pass so nobody will go anywhere
while you're doing those things but when
you sit down and talk to people time
passes I guess that makes sense should
we talk to that guy this customer's a
journalist
I was originally looking into these
suspicious deaths that have been
happening lately I'm Justin by the way
hmm I see you're drinking a Cuba Libre
have we met him before I don't remember
a guy with beard and glasses I see
excuse me oh yeah the legend anyway in
my research I found records indicating
that similar cases occurred in hundred
year cycles many men died last time as
well it's the truth no [ __ ] 300 years
every hundred years the strange
variation on this legend going around -
and I keep talking like this I don't
know why dreams
very very rarely there's a man who is
cursed but doesn't die isn't that
interesting it's said that this survivor
is granted one wish if he wished for
eternal youth
this is what you're coming in with it'll
wish in mind for yourself to live
forever left you typical me I wish for
something different like what you may
wish to change the past someone kill me
what that's [ __ ] rough all right
that's my time to get the [ __ ] out let's
talk to these sexy training you know
what did I say granny's obviously mind
if I say oh my god they're so creepy
okay you haven't even finish your beer
[Music]
you can go home at any time from the
door in the front so the conversations
will change as well laughs I walk such
an awkward posture should we check out
some of these stuff I feel like we've
done enough of those kind of things
already and we explored probably
everything that you can think probably
not actually but wait what you say that
just when I sit down
he pretends not to mind I think it still
gets to him sometimes even when his wife
calls them what do you mean nevermind
think is about damn time we head home
without saying bye to our friends
[Music]
crashed out in front of your place we
should take her home if you know what I
mean but maybe now we'll actually play
some puzzle games it's like this puzzle
game they turn into this like this I
feel like it could be like a stupid app
like the gameplay totally works but it's
kind of like candy crush it's like this
elaborate whole thing around can occur
[Music]
plus we didn't reply to Katherine hey yo
is it gonna be another nightmare maybe 9
yeah alright so since we drank a line I
don't know how that will affect this
well it's time to go inside the
nightmare
I really thought like the main thing
about the game would be the torture
chamber first floor so traumatic I loved
it thank you for the tip and food random
man I really thought it would be all
about this puzzled part but it's very
little in comparison
I wanna thought they told you Vincent
that it would be every every night for
five nights eight nights oh my god he
[ __ ] told me not to walk on it and
it's the first thing I do good job me
all right I lose a pillow but you know
what I can live with it oh this is
stressing me the [ __ ] out the floor is
falling - Jesus Christ okay we're at a
good place here maybe okay I'm not I've
[ __ ] the coins I'm not gonna go for
that [ __ ] at this point I'm probably
just gonna [ __ ] die how do we get up
there it's not making anything stupid
right now that we know where our mom's
gonna regret we can push this forward
[Music]
let's do that again
ooh fantastic fantastic just what I
wanted I was born to do this [ __ ] oh
we're almost at the top okay all right
all right all right
can we do it yes we can
wow that was so hard
[Music]
[Applause]
man I'm so proud I'm proud of you
breasts mainly because I love you save
that one for the bank do that easy
oh my god and I got a bra well you know
what maybe next playthrough I'm
definitely I feel like I know already I
can play through this game again it's
[ __ ] awesome alright so now we're at
the church which is like the Midway we
get to talk to the sheeps hello there
blonde guy with glasses sheep with
sunglasses that's just standing around
I'm looking at for myself
yeah the rebel renegade alright well
let's keep playing
fantastic should we talk to these you
talk to him I'm not gonna buy anything I
have my book
let's talk to you
[Music]
then Catherine is the one don't you
think
and stuck to this [ __ ] I was scared
afraid afraid of me okay we heard that
that's what I was thinking too can we
talk to him we're to watch out for those
we would never push anyway anyway
alright let's go to the confessional I'm
excited this question
you wrote should answer to what I'm not
ready ever again thank you this is your
dream what appears depends on you I
can't let you carry your memories of
your dream back into the real world if
you were to try anything in reality oh
that's really creepy
[Music]
here we go hello you gets jumpscared
every time a beautiful countryside or
somewhere where I can get a drink
alright alright alright we're going more
on the devil side it does matter for
this story thank you
on the eighth floor there's a cathedral
[Music]
I'm open to them and of course from this
nightmare as well so if I climb to the
very top I'll be saved I have said too
much I'll guide you to the next trial
Cathedral huh okay fine so we'll
remember everything once we made it out
that's really interesting but we're not
done with stage three are we
I see what other people answered ah okay
the boys boys yep all right what about
girls oh that's similar it isn't
everyone
I picked the minority answering everyone
haven't I except one maybe all right
we're halfway there Bruce let's finish
this off torture chambers second floor
we're not halfway there with third we're
there
[Music]
okay yeah I [ __ ] hate those [ __ ]
traps
I'm starting to learn a little bit I
feel like that was really useful the
last level cuz it's so hard
oh god [ __ ] I'm so tired of Miss
clicking it pisses me off I wish I had
it like a spell that made me
[Music]
why did it see why did I do that now I
have to do all this work to get Oh God
foxy
[Music]
okay here we go
give me that sweet edge baby it's all I
want
[ __ ] mine money diamonds and [ __ ]
don't need them okay I'm so sorry here
we go
put you there starting to learn how to
play this game I hope you bros are proud
of me
under damn it why did I do that that was
the wrong word now I have to do this I
can put you there though and maybe take
you out take your baby out for a drink
let me suck on your sink okay we're
doing pretty good well paste great job
for us you're not doing anything what I
call your prose I don't know that's
weird
okay go go go oh that was close wait
there's a pillow we're going for the
pillow bros we got a pillow give me that
sweet pillow don't fall please god damn
it all right we're still good oh we're
still good neom us probably a mess as we
say in Sweden at that farm of a bleep
closer walk yeah poke for that began 11
while my family that means I love you in
Swedish and I want you to live a nice
life
oh my god did he make it nope
can we push these alright I ride all
right
Oh God Jesus what have I done why did it
well you've done it nap hits this is not
in triggering
oh you triggered them there we go
alright alright thank you sheep a
checkpoint would just be [ __ ] swell
right now there it is
give it to me yeah Bruce Wow doing
amazing no I'm not amazing a moon that's
how you say it say it say it oh my god
I can't [ __ ] hear you Jesus Christ
it's adorable
okay money or okay here I don't know why
I feel like the other level was so much
harder she did the bridge thing look at
that bridge oh it's after you walk in
the Travie breaks oh my god are you
kidding me I didn't know that come on
man oh [ __ ]
so you have to walk as - okay I
understand the traps now it's okay you
know what sometimes you have to fail to
fully learn can we got that [ __ ] look at
this edge edge edge look at that [ __ ]
[Music]
get good
now let's push this bridge give me that
edge Oh God give me that edge there it
is
that's what I'm talking about pull it
and then go up we escaped gross
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing amazing absolutely astonishing
grid John however we have one more to go
before [ __ ] bronze man come on come
on man
yeah one more to go before we begin my
hole bro
no okay great fantastic it's just the
looking more like a church should
probably say not you know what I left in
there because I'd kind of late and I've
been playing along
sorry bro so I really wanted to do one
every day all right
I think it was so much for all amazing
support keep leaving likes I really
appreciate him and I'll see you tomorrow
they also present
[Music]